c'est un un Alexis que de mobilisation
il y a une volonté aussi de s'enraciner
de ce légitimer remercier ses soutiens
rassembler les Français et mobiliser
pour la suite
5 années de transformation d'heures
heureuses et difficiles de crise
exceptionnelle aussi
ce jour
du 24 avril 2022 une majorité d'entre
nous a fait le choix de me faire
confiance pour présider notre République
durant les cinq années à venir
[Applaudissements]
c'est une victoire qui est quand même
acquise dans des conditions très
particulières avec une très forte
opposition une très forte hostilité dans
un climat difficile dans un climat
fracturé et l'excès de joie aurait tout
de suite été interprété comme une
inconscience une arrogance un mépris il
y a la structure même du discours qui
est toujours en trois temps remercier
ses soutiens
rassembler les Français et mobiliser
pour la suite c'est un discours assez
classique pour une fin de campagne
électorale c'est une deuxième victoire
c'est une réélection donc il n'est pas
dans la conquête du pouvoir mais
simplement dans la poursuite de son
exercice là on a des manuel Macron qui
est entouré par des militants sur une
estrade avec en fond la Tour Eiffel pour
l'hymne à la joie qui accompagne
musicalement l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron
donc européen il y a donc l'idée de
placer son mandat sous le signe de
l'Union européenne bien évidemment sur
la forme ce qui est nouveau c'est cette
déambulation préalable au discours qui
cette fois-ci se fait accompagner il y
avait eu une déambulation dans la
courgette du Louvre on s'en souvient
mais une déambulation solitaire alors
que là il y a une déambulation avec
Brigitte Macron et avec un certain
nombre d'enfants c'est encore une fois
un discours très classique de
remerciements à ceux qui ont fait la
campagne c'est très important parce que
ce sont des gens qui sont à ce moment-là
face à lui et qui ont besoin que on les
remercie du travail accompli alors je
vous remercier l'ensemble des militants
des volontaires
des compagnons de route élus qui depuis
le début m'accompagne je sais que vous
n'avez pas ménagé vos efforts avait
donné tant d'énergie partagée tant de
conviction c'est en frappant au cœur que
vient la vérité
merci
et je sais ce que je vous dois
c'est air nouvelle ne sera pas la
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
mais l'invention collective d'une
méthode refondée pour cinq années de
mieux au service de notre pays de notre
jeunesse
alors ça c'est toujours quelque chose
d'intéressant la rhétorique d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est l'omnipré présence du RE il
recréer refondent et donc on a eu de
nouveau l'idée de refonder une une
politique et puis la toute fin la
péroraison entre nous il y aura une
responsabilité
plein d'entre nous
aura un si engagé car chacun d'entre
nous compte plus que lui-même
c'est ce qui fait
du peuple français
cette force singulière
que j'aime si profondément si
intensément et que je suis si fier de
servir à nouveau
[Applaudissements]
mettre à disposition l'idée d'aimer donc
à vocabulaire du sentiment de l'affect
et c'est déjà quelque chose qu'on avait
trouvé en 2017 ou il avait fini en
disant je vous servirai avec amour c'est
l'emploi de tous ces concepts
mobilisateurs sur l'écologie la
République le social la création la
force et donc tout ça ne recouvre pas
nécessairement grand chose mais ce sont
des vocabulaires rassembleurs je sais
aussi
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
et je veux ici
les remercier et leur dire que j'ai
conscience que ce vote m'oblige pour les
années à venir je pense aussi à tous nos
compatriotes qui se sont abstenus
leur silence a signifié un refus de
choisir
auquel nous nous devrons aussi de
répondre je pense enfin à ceux qui ont
voté pour Madame Le Pen dont je sais la
déception ce soir non le sifflet
personne
depuis le début je vous ai demandé de ne
jamais siffler l'appel à l'unité c'est
un passage obligé on lui aurait reproché
de ne pas le faire il est
institutionnellement le président de
tous les Français il ne peut pas faire
autrement dès à présent
je ne suis plus le candidat d'un camp
mais le président de toutes et tous
l'idée qu'il soit le président de tous
les Français peut être considéré comme
un vœu pieux peut être considéré comme
une posture mais dans un discours de
victoire c'est un passage absolument
obligé pour des raisons à la fois
institutionnelles et politiques donc un
signal donné aux électeurs de Marine Le
Pen aux abstentionnistes on a beaucoup
souligné la sobriété et l'absence de
triomphalisme de ce discours cette
solennité et cette sobriété elle
correspond aux conditions de sa victoire